[Music]
[Applause]
yes
we have attached a racket to a stick
so this is one of the world's longest
table tennis rackets ever probably but
let's see if we can play with it
[Music]
oh that's a really good spin actually
[Music]
whoa
ah
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
nice one
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm finding the rhythm
[Music]
whoa
yeah exactly out first
it's not working so well
next is an instagram challenge from
johnny wins he wants us to play with the
table
i think it's the biggest racket i've
ever had
[Music]
so
oh
[Music]
this is how you play table tennis with
the table
[Music]
should i cut that one also but
no can do
so last time we sliced an apple and this
time we'll try a banana
no
this is not gonna work
[Music]
no not gonna happen
[Applause]
[Music]
come on
[Music]
yes i did it that was a perfect hit
yes
look at that straight in the middle
[Music]
now remember to subscribe to our channel
here
and watch our previous videos there
until next time